♪ ♪ ♪
- En plein coeur de New York,
ces grandes tentes blanches
détonnent. Une mesure
d'urgence prise par la ville
pour accueillir les milliers
de migrants qui arrivent en bus
du Texas depuis le mois de mai.
♪ ♪ ♪
"Le Texas n'avertit pas, dit-il
quand ils envoient un bus rempli
de migrants."
♪ ♪ ♪
L'endroit est surveillé
24 heures sur 24, la garde
nationale, des agents de firmes
privés sont sur le qui-vive.
On protège l'endroit
des citoyens, nous dit-on.
Silvina Sterin est journaliste
pour RFI espagne, et rapporte
quotidiennement sur la crise
migratoire.
"On voit tout sauf des migrants,
dit-elle, l'endroit est froid,
peu accueillant."
Les medias y ont eu accès
unululule fois. Des télévisions,
des téléphones et des machines
à laver sont disponibles pour
s s s nouveaux arrivants.
New York veut remplir son devoir
moral, et respecter la loi
qui l'oblige à héberger tous
les citoyens de la ville.
"Envoyez-moi vos fatigués,
vos pauvres, vos cohortes
qui aspirent à vivre libres",
dit la statue de la Liberté.
Les voilà donc...
"Il faut s'assurer que les gens
soient traités humainement,
dit-il, mais on ne se bouscule
pas aurtrtrtillons pour
accueillir les réfugiés."
"Pas dans ma cours" me disent
des élus", dit le maire excédé,
qui fait déjà face à une crise
du logement.
Car l'arrivée des migrants,
s'ajoute au niveau record
des sans-abri dans la ville.
Près de 64 000 personnes sont
sans domicile fixe à New York.
Le moratoire pour empêcher
les expulsions de locataire
durant lndndndémie prend fin.
Sans compter l'inflation,
le coût exorbitant des loyers,
qui dans certains cas,
a augmenté de 35 %.
Certains locataires se
retrouvent donc dans la rue.
La ville réclame près
d'un milliard de dollars
du gouvernement fédéral
et déclare l'état d'urgence.
C'est donc ici, dans ce lieu
hautement sécurisé que
le maire de New York espère
installer 500 hommes migrants,
mais déjà, les critiques
affluent parce que cette
installation est très loin
du centre-ville.
Pour le moment, ligigigrants
sont éparpillés à travers
la ville dans des hôtels.
Comme Yeni, son mari et
ses deux enfants, qui
sont arrivés de la ville
del Paso il y a une semaine.
"La situation politique
au Venezuela est difficile,
dit-elle, la violence extrême."
Iuiuiuittent alors la ville
de Victoria en septembre pour
entamer leur long périple vers
l'eldorado américain. Ils onttr,
le Nicaragua...
"Le Guatemala est la partie
dure, dit-elle, puis le Mexique
avant d'arriver àfrfrfrontière
américaine." Ils ont marché
parfois 12 heures par jour...
"Les autorités vénézuéliennes
nous ont dit, : "Si vous ne
sortez pas voter, nous allons
brûler vos maisons"", dit-elle.
Ça été l'élément déclencheur
pour partir. Depuis 2015,
7 millions de Vénézuéliens
ont quitté leur pays.
Une fois sur place,
à New York, l'organisation
caritative catholique Catholic
Charities les prend en charge.
"On leur fournit différent
services-e-e-elle, ils peuvent
postuler pour des assurances
médicales, une carte d'identité
de New York, inscrire
leurs enfants à l'école."
Mais ces réfugiés, ballotés
d'un État à un autre,
sont la cible des campagnes
électorales républicaines à
deux semaines des élections
de mi-mandat.
On parle de tentes luxueuses
pour ces nouveaux arrivants,
alors que les américains peinent
à s'en sortir avec l'inflation.
"Ce sont des trafiquants
de drogues, d'humains, qui
contrôlent nos frontières",
dit Kari Lake, la candidate
républicaine en Arizona
au poste de gouverneur.
"On ne sait pas qui ils sont."
Sur la chaîne Fox, on parle
d'invasion, de grand
remplacement, de futurs
électeurs démocrates.
"Ils utilisent les migrants
pour marquer des points",
dit-elle.
"Le fait que le Texas s'en
débarrasse comme si ils étaient
pestiférés, c'est horrible",
dit-elle.
Mais peu importe, Les tentes
sont prêtes à les accueillir
avant l'hiver, nous dit-on.
♪ ♪ ♪
Yeni et son mari, eux, veulent,
envoyer leurs enfants à l'école
et travailler le plus tôt
possible, et surtout, ne pas
être un fardeau pour le système.
Ici Azeb Wolde-Giorgis,
Radio-Canada, New Yor